well good evening London welcome to
Piers Morgan uncensored uh well Harry
and Megan uh sorry to keep banging on
about them but I keep banging on about
everybody else don't they so we have no
choice until they get exhausted and we
all get exhausted and we can all move on
but for now they remain in the position
that they are demanding an apology from
the royal family for all the filth that
they've thrown at the royal family in
the last two years
but why should the royal family
apologize when you consider what's
happened with Jeremy Clarkson
now Clarkson wrote what he is admitted
was a stupid and inflammatory newspaper
column that overstepped the mark the
outrage was predictable and it was
frankly Justified as he now concedes but
he apologized on Twitter said he got it
completely wrong then on Christmas day
he wrote directly to Prince Harry on
Christmas day think about that and
yesterday he issued a sprawling shame
face self-immolation of a public apology
about as groveling as it could be I
really am sorry he pleaded all the way
from the balls of my feet to the
follicles of my head this is me putting
my hands up into Mia culpa with belzon
it doesn't get more fullsome frankly
than what he posted on Instagram and
coming from Clarkson it would probably
rather shoot himself and be like that
normally it carried even more weight
but it wasn't enough
for Harry and Megan and he took me back
actually to when I was asked to
apologize to Megan Markle for doubting
her word on Good Morning Britain and one
of the reasons I refused was why would I
apologize a for something I believe I.E
she lies and secondly if I did Apologize
what do you think would happen
anyway even if I pretended that I was
sorry they wouldn't accept it she
wouldn't accept it she'd just use that
as an excuse to go even harder it's what
they do they're the victims always
perennial victims
so I refused and I left and I'm very
happy about that because I wouldn't be
here doing my show if I hadn't done that
but Clarkson is now in a similar
position looking like he may possibly
lose a lucrative and highly popular
series of shows on Amazon Prime perhaps
even Who Wants To Be A Millionaire at
ITV and you might have your own view
either way about whether Clarkson should
be canceled in this way I don't think it
he should be I don't think that
punishment fits the crime of a stupid
joke and a column
into the apology
they were desperate for an apology from
Clarkson simply so they could reject it
they could have accepted it noted it
people ignored it but instead they
reveled in it pouring fuel on the Flames
of his humiliation without as they
lashed him in a statement for writing
articles that spread hate rhetoric
dangerous conspiracy theories and
misogyny it's clear this is not an
isolated incident shared in haste they
said but rather a series of Articles
shared in hate got the dripping
pomposity of that statement
and the disingenuousness of it
Harry let us remind ourselves it's just
literally just published a best-selling
416 page book which is effectively a
series of Articles shared in hate and
when it comes to misogyny he like his
wife identifies Arch feminists and yet
here he is and we've gone to the audio
book to put it in his own words
describing the disabled matron that he
mocked at school
unlike the other matrons Pat wasn't hot
Pat was called Pat was small walking was
hard stairs were torture she descend
backwards glacially
often we stand on the landing below her
doing antique dances making faces
do I need to say which boy did this with
the most enthusiasm we went on mocking
her as she came down the stairs the
reward was worth the risk
for me the reward wasn't tormenting poor
Pat but making my mates laugh
where's Pat's apology
and what about the first woman he slept
with
suspected he was referring to my recent
loss of virginity in glorious episode
with an older woman she liked horses
quite a lot and treated me not unlike a
young stallion quick ride after which
she'd smack my rump and sent me off to
graze among the many things about it
that were wrong it happened in a grassy
field behind a busy Pub
that'd be a way to talk about this older
woman a private citizen who's now the
subject of global mockery
who is that woman does he care about the
way he talked about her
it's not exactly chivalrous is it to
reveal stuff like that in a book that's
been read by millions around the world
but it's her apology
and how about the female newspaper
editor the Harry really didn't like
who the hell is this editor loathsome
toad I gathered
everyone who knew her was in full
agreement that she was an infected
posture on the ass of humanity plus an
excuse for a journalist an infected
pustule on the ass of humanity what does
that say with
being nice to women
being supportive of a woman being a
feminist
where's the apology for that female
newspaper editor
is it going to be one for that blatant
misogyny and what about Camilla the
queen console his own stepmother
she was the villain
she was the third person in the marriage
she needed to rehabilitate Her Image in
a funny way I even wanted Camilla to be
happy maybe she'd be less dangerous if
she was happy
his own stepmother the love of his
father's life our Queen to be she'll be
coronated too
a dangerous villain
where's Camilla's apology
for that hateful rhetoric
you see my point here
if anyone should be groveling for
forgiveness and issuing apologies isn't
it Harry and Megan
for selling all the family secrets to
the highest bidders for allowing the
Royals to be smeared as racist and then
say oh we didn't mean to do that two
years later for allowing Britain to be
cast as a bigoted hell hole
but they won't ever apologize for any of
it because they're Hypocrites they're
professional victims who wallow for a
living and as I point apologizing to
professional victims I knew that when I
was asked to apologize to Meghan Markle
two years ago
why would you when they do what they did
to Jeremy Clarkson it's not about
forgiveness anyway it's about scoring
points to humiliate their enemies to
reinforce that victimhood